let's think back to what we did just
immediately previous to this right when
you shoot us a few different ideas in
particular we looked at when you're
arranging things you know we stepped
away from probability for a little while
and just think about I've got a bunch of
things and I want to arrange them okay
when the order matters we gave that a
special man we called them permutations
very good okay and then we notice there
are really two kinds of permutations
okay two kind and it's based on whether
you replace what you're arranging or you
don't replace okay so when you do
replace okay and if you got an object
and you want to arrange K of them right
and objects K plot spots to put them
into you okay
what's the number of regulars with
replacement anyone remember we had
replacement right so our example is the
four-digit pin it wasn't it okay and
you're like over ten options here ten
options here to attach oh so wait you
got n different things to choose from
right it's that times itself however
many number of spots you need to put it
into and that's why we're that four
digit PIN we said look you've got ten
different digits then you can put in
there and your four spots to put it in
so tender for ten thousand options okay
then we said all right if you don't
replace it rather than say numbers on a
keypad you are thinking about horses in
a race and one horse can't be first and
second and third so it's a scenario with
that replacement right then we got into
seven factorials now before we do that
fancy notation that we introduce right
what was it in factorial notation how do
we write it in terms of ends in case
started with n factorial
and then I have to divide by what do I
divide by n minus K factorial we said
look this is so important it's such a
big deal it gets its own notation namely
okay all right sir
so far so good look at some interesting
cases of this right I want to go after
this up without replacement situation
because of your life it's far more
common when I'm arranging stuff by using
actual objects and I can't repeat them
so here we go
special case okay let's look at an easy
special case when you're actually pretty
familiar with okay what if I've got any
objects right and I just want to arrange
all of them okay so for example you know
it's not a horse races before right
first second third suppose I only have
three horses right so everyone's good to
get a place everyone wins kind of you
know it's like I came I came third in a
group of three now how many ways are
there to arrange them well let's think
of it through this lens okay think of it
through this lens um the example we're
looking at these three horses so I've
got three things to choose from right
and I want to pick out or commute three
of them 3p 3sat all right so what this
has become when we go to factorial
notation it's not that hard
you got three factorial on the top what
do you have on the denominator you have
that zero vectorial that we talked at
zero factorial earlier in the year
didn't we right here is another reason
why 0 factorial must be one because it
wouldn't make sense if it was anything
else
right so though it's 3 factorial which
of course is 6 but so more generally
speaking we could say and
the M is equal to n factorial right we
actually know this we've looked at this
before we just haven't captured it in
these kinds of terms right I mean more
specifically is in factorial and zero
factorial but that's always just the
coil